[Music]
some of you both looking at me looking
at the champion thinking why is the
champ wearing
why is he wearing a long hat this is a
nigerian i've just come back from
nigeria i like the hat i like the
clothes i like the food i like the
country so i thought i'd bring some of
it back with me and present it to the
people but today we're not going to be
talking about west africa in particular
those are very interesting topic history
the geography the people the climate and
so on we're going to be talking about
uh using philosophy in particular the
contingency argument in dawa now why am
i even bringing this up obviously i've
written a book on the contingency
argument many of you may have purchased
it many of you may not have purchased it
if you haven't this is the book here
it's called
it's uh published the sapiens institute
actually you can get it free of charge
sapiens institute we uh publish these
things free of charge but the the
paperback version you're gonna have to
pay for the materials
uh but you can get it free of charge now
i'm doing my phd also on the contingency
argument so obviously something which is
very interesting to me
uh so recently some individuals who
self-proclaimed salafis
have come out and critiqued the use of
the contingency argument in the first
place so you should be using this
uh this is not what the people of the
salaf did it's not people of you know
did and so on
the three people and so this is wrong
and so today what we're going to be
doing is just looking at some things i
have already made a video about using
kalam
and i've mentioned in particular the
positions of ebentamia and you can see
the video of that um somewhere else
maybe i'll put it in the description box
but i'll start off with just reading
something that even tamiya wrote in his
book
and today is going to be an exposition
of what even tamiya said because the the
point is this if eben said me as someone
who's trustworthy
their perspective if you consider him to
be
the majed and the things that obviously
we consider him to be
a great figure of the history of islam
he knows the qidah of the athar and so
on then in that case obviously
you wouldn't consider him a deviant
you wouldn't consider his perspectives
deviant ones my perspectives may be
deviant perspectives his perspective
that person but even tamil let's start
with what he says in his
i've presented this one before but
i've got some things today which i've
never presented in public he says
we've already kind of said this one
before he says that some people
some individuals
every time that the dele was or the
evidence was more sophisticated and more
hidden if you like and has more premises
and it was longer to elaborate then it
was
better for that individual because his
self has
gotten used to that kind of thing
was only a few premises
very obvious
he wasn't going to be happy with that
like this
uh and he goes on and he actually even
mentioned some benefits
doing this will strengthen the sharpen
the mind and so on
but interestingly with the contingency
so this is the first thing the first
thing is when it comes to using kalam
mantec whatever eben tamiya himself
is saying that with some people you need
to use those kinds of arguments that is
what he is saying in his book one of the
last books that he's published but what
about the contingency argument itself
one very central aspect of the
contingency argument is of course
the in
the infinity or
uh the set of infinite things effect of
self-finite things et cetera
and this is in a kitab called minheja
sunnah pages
436-437 i'm going to put the screenshot
on the screen
and where this is what he says he said
what
he says that
infinite regress is of two types
he basically says infinite regressors of
two types and one type is
uh the infinite rigors of inefficient
causes and this is impossible yeah with
the
fact with the agreement of all the
rational people
willing
as if to say for example this originated
thing has an originator and this
originated the originator has an
originator and this
uh infinitely regressive backwards what
does this sound like ladies and
gentlemen this is philosophizing ibm
tamiya here is philosophizing he is
using the which is not in the quran and
the sunnah this infinite regress calam
he is speaking of it himself he's using
it himself
now i want to know what is your response
to this how do you feel about if i were
to say these things maybe it's a deviant
position but even tamiya is saying it
himself him and how just on that page
436 436-437
he says because this is the second page
now
second page here we go it says because
every muh death every originated thing
that cannot originate itself
so it is not
it's not uh it is uh absent
with regard to itself
and it's contingent now let's talk about
contingency is he
is he thought yes he is yes
yes
yes he is he says
it says contingent with regard to itself
so if it's something which is
understood
uh two infinite
infinite regressive proportions
this particular set of things
or
uh is and it could not be
self-sufficient or in existence because
of itself in the imam
the fact that you have contingent things
contingent upon contingent things
that does not mean that that entire set
is not itself contingent on some agency
outside of itself
in fact the more you add contingent
things to contingent things
the more you'll require
um
the more it will depend on the agent
the ultimate agent
is too
so for example two contingent things
or two originated things or two
contingent things is even more dependent
than one of them
yeah on the agent
this doesn't mean that the contingent
thing will at one point there'll be a
threshold where it stops being
contingent in fact it continues being
even more
uh contingent
so this is the first thing clearly he's
speaking about contingencies clearly
he's making the argument clearly he's
agreeing with the argument clearly he
doesn't agree with those individuals who
say that you can't use the argument he
does not agree with that he's in fact
using the argument
himself
he is using the argument himself
and he uses it even more in this kitab
here which is once again
and you can look in fact the whole
section page 426-432
is very interesting the discussion
because he anticipates the cosmological
fallacy
much like you know the bertrand
russellian compositional fallacy that
just because this there is some kind of
description in the part doesn't mean
that that will be generalized to the
whole
well then he responds and this is a long
discussion i can't show all
so he's saying here that if you put
together things which are non-existent
yes it does not uh
which are contingent it doesn't make it
existent
when you put these particular
instantiations of contingent things
together
in fact it doesn't change its um quality
he states
uh if you even if you put it together
it still remains
dependent
i spoke about this in another segment
someone may argue actually he has a
serious problem and he did have a
serious problem
with
um
some of the way the philosopher like ibn
cena and farabi and kindly and so on
they use this argument
to do nephew of this effect
to
to negate some of the attributes of god
and yes you can see this for example in
the quotation above and suffer
when his kitab called the safari from
page number 104 to 111
but what he says
is really interesting as i'll show he
says it elsewhere is that it really
depends on how you define a part in a
whole for example allah
for example if you can separate these
things together
like for example there are the
appendages of a human being then uh or
that you can you shall elay for example
kashmir falak
then these things are not what are
intended by composite parts
he says
now he's attacking the philosopher he's
saying that if we're talking about
attributes and that the establishment
a composition
meaning these two examples
he's saying that each of the suffix of
allah are necessary so the attributes of
god are necessary whereas a part of the
thing that can be taken away and put
into that's not necessary that is not
necessary even tell me they're telling
you this it's not me that's telling you
this it's even telling me that's telling
you this and he says it again
in
page 91 so if you look at the two just
that they are separate from each other
so that uh amore puts them together
a moroccan puts them together so here
he's saying he's showing you the problem
that he has with the compositional
argument that even cena makes
he's saying that basically they are
conflating between an attribute and
a part he's saying basically it's
something like he gives two examples for
example a ship that has lots of planks
yeah
these are the parts that can be put in
or taken out or food that is made up of
many different ingredients
these are the kinds of parts that is
impossible for hakilah
therefore in tamiya he tweaks the
contingency argument
because even cena and the philosopher
don't really make this distinction they
conflate between the attribute
and
the part
so the question is how do in my book
i've actually accounted for this so you
can see
in how i describe a uh a part we've
described it in english as a piece
because the word piece in english
language
it has already the denotation that it
can only be put in or taken out and that
is impossible with allah for example we
say a piece of cake
whereas the word part in myriology you
can say a part of his personality
like part of his personality or the
attributes of god has got many different
attributes so the word part is confusing
from that perspective so in order to
eliminate the confusion i use the word
peace and we can't say allah has pieces
so having all of these things bearing
all these things in mind
there should be if someone is saying
there's a problem with using the
contingency argument
and they are making that claim now your
problem is no longer with muhammad hijab
let me sorry to
say this your problem is no longer
with muhammad hijab your problem is with
ibn tamiya himself now all of your
refutations in your pdfs please write
them with the title refuting ibntamia
because this is very clear i've given
you more than three or four references
that's four references four different
books where ebony is saying things
now you can say well he's saying these
things out of context i'm giving you the
entire reference i've shown it to you on
the screen
i've read it out to you in the arabic
and translated it to you in english
maybe
maybe you don't understand this with all
due respect maybe you don't understand
what's going on here but just because
you don't understand something it
doesn't mean now you have a right to
block people from doing dawah to
atheists because you're not doing dawah
to atheists you cannot do that show us
how to do dawah demonstrate to us how
you can do dao to atheists without using
first principle methods
so anyway i mean i don't want to waste
my time too much but the point is is
that we just want people to know who
allah is
and we just want people to understand
that you can use these arguments in
islam and islam is a rational religion
that's why even himself wrote
this lack of contradiction between the
knuckle or the textual evidence as an
article i hope with all of this evidence
i'm no longer going to receive
questions from the
hammer the general public and whatever
and other people
videos being made and so on about the
contingency argument unless these
quotations are dealt with
if you deal with these quotations
please i would love to see how these
quotations are wrong so i can amend my
thesis my phd thesis so i can speak to
my friends
so so we can improve our knowledge
together otherwise
it's just going to be name calling and
uh
and blocking the way of dao with all due
respect so instead of blocking the way
of dao and name calling let's stick to
the academia let's stick to the
references if you cannot deal with these
references and you cannot respond to
them just it's no it's not a shame to
say you know i was wrong on the matter
was
you